Hey, David, you talk about undecided voters.
Who the hell could possibly be undecided right
now about Trump versus Biden?
I agree with the sentiment.
I've said before almost verbatim, who the
hell could be undecided right now?
Only if you've not been paying attention.
Right.
Could you be undecided at this point.
And that indeed is the case if you look at
who are number one swing voters.
And number two, who is undecided right now.
What you find is that the undecideds and swing
voters tend to be younger.
Centrists to center right.
Less engaged in politics.
They aren't actually paying attention.
So, for example, 72 percent of voters who
are 65 or older have decided for sure they
know who they're going to vote for among 18
to 29 year olds.
Only 47 percent were decided.
As of a few weeks ago.
That's crazy.
But it makes sense in from the standpoint
of if you don't know that much about what's
going on, you're more likely to say, I don't
know who I'm going to vote for or whether
I'm going to vote.
It is people who are paying less attention.
It is people who are less informed.
If you are remotely informed and you are a
likely voter.
You voted before or you're sure that you're
going to vote.
It's tough to be undecided right now.
We've had almost four years now of impossibly
dramatic differences between what Donald Trump
has done and how he has governed and what
a Joe Biden presidency would mean to the United
States.
Now, the other question about undecideds is
a lot of undecideds don't think it's that
important whether one candidate or the other
candidate wins.
In other words, when you ask all voters whether
it matters who wins, 82 percent to 92 percent
say that it matters.
When you ask these swing and undecided voters.
Does it matter who wins?
Only two thirds believe that it matters.
So you start to put together a picture of
the undecided voter tends to be younger.
Ideologically, they are moderate to center
right.
They aren't paying much attention and they
don't think that the quiet consequences actually
matter that much.
That makes sense.
If you fall under those categories, it follows
logically.
I don't agree with those points of view, but
it follows logically that you might say may
me maybe, maybe Trump, maybe Biden.
Those who are politically engaged have overwhelmingly
been decided for a long time.
Those who have voted in the past have been
overwhelmingly decided for a long time.
And in terms of issues.
One other interesting tidbit is that people
who are still undecided today or as of about
two weeks ago, not only are they more uninformed,
they tend to vote based on their gut feeling
of how the economy is doing and their gut
feeling more generally.
That tracks, sadly, with someone who could
be bamboozled, essentially tricked into voting
for Donald Trump.
And that's what's very, very scary.
And why I am repeating and hammering on and
harping on.
We need every vote.
We've got to run up the vote in the blue states.
We've got to get as many possible votes in
red states, even if they are states that Biden
will certainly lose.
Don't assume anything whatsoever because gut
feeling about the economy is exactly who's
being targeted when Trump says biggest job
growth in one month ever will.
Yeah.
After record losses.
Right.
Those are the folks that go.
I don't know.
It just kind of sounds like things are pretty
good.
The stock market looks OK.
This is why they pour money into the stock
market to reach those exact voters.